eu finance ministers have approved an
updated mandate to finalize negotiations
with the european parliament on the
establishment of a single resolution
mechanism for banks
the council wants the talks to be
concluded in time for the plenary
session in april before the end of the
current parliamentary term
these discussions in council on all
these issues
were extensive
difficult
but constructive
and we have arrived at the new updated
mandate of the council to the presidency
which allows us
the necessary flexibility to go to trial
tomorrow with the parliament the single
resolution mechanism is one of the key
elements of the banking union it aims to
enable in-depth restructuring of banks
in serious financial problems
the council also discussed tougher rules
on the taxation of savings income the
idea is to enable member states to
better clamp down on tax fraud and tax
evasion
the presidency hopes the new rules will
be adopted before the end of march
following endorsement by eu leaders
ministers have also exchanged views on
the economic elements of the eu 2030
energy and climate framework